-Bonjour et bienvenue.
Je suis très heureuse
de vous retrouver sur LCP
pour un "Maman j'ai arrêté l'avion"
consacré, cette fois,
à la mer, notre mer à tous.
La grande bleue n'a jamais été
aussi pillée, polluée, profanée.
Profanée, c'est le mot.
L'océan est pourtant sacré :
il absorbe près d'un tiers
de nos émissions de CO2
et régule le climat.
Notre avenir est directement indexé
à sa santé.
Or, plus on le dégrade
et moins il joue son rôle
de thermostat planétaire.
Réchauffement, pollution,
surpêche, acidification, algues,
rien ne va plus,
Raphaël ?
-Oui, à l'échelle de la planète,
nous prélevons chaque année
90 millions de tonnes
de poissons ou coquillages,
ce qui fait en moyenne par Français
24 kilos par an.
Une consommation qui a doublé
depuis les années 60.
Autre chiffre fort, on estime
que l'activité humaine a divisé
par 3, voire 5, la quantité
de poissons dans les océans,
et même par 10
sur les régions littorales.
L'aquaculture ne change pas
grand-chose à l'affaire.
Pour nourrir le poisson d'élevage,
on pêche du poisson sauvage.
-Plus la demande monte,
plus les océans se vident,
avec une pêche
toujours plus intensive,
plus industrialisée
et plus subventionnée,
au détriment de la biodiversité,
des écosystèmes
et des petits pêcheurs.
Comment protéger l'océan
quand les aires marines protégées
n'ont de protégées que le nom
et que la pêche industrielle
a le vent dans le dos ?
Au fait, maman,
j'ai arrêté l'avion.
Générique
...
Pour en parler,
la lauréate du prix Goldman 2018,
le Nobel de l'environnement,
Claire Nouvian,
fondatrice de BLOOM,
l'ONG qui donne des cauchemars
aux lobbies
et du fil à retordre
aux politiques.
L'un de ses représentants,
l'eurodéputé et président
de la commission pêche
à l'Europe,
Pierre Karleskind,
est en duplex pour lui répondre,
et pour nous éclairer,
un économiste de la biodiversité,
le chercheur et professeur
d'économie écologique
à AgroParisTech
et à l'université Paris-Saclay,
Harold Levrel.
Bonjour à tous.
Avant de vous donner la parole,
immersion dans le monde de la pêche
et des poissons d'élevage.
Plus les océans se vident,
plus on cherche des alternatives.
Plutôt que de chercher
à faire des écosystèmes sains,
on affine nos techniques de pêche
et on mise sur l'aquaculture,
la solution à la pénurie,
pour certains,
mais ce nouvel eldorado
est loin d'être neutre.
Le Tout oppose, c'est un reportage
d'Emma Guizot et Ibar Aibar.
-Loctudy, en Bretagne.
Il est 10h du matin.
Sur son petit chalutier
de 8,50 mètres,
Jonathan Firmin rentre
d'une nuit entière de pêche
avec un bien maigre butin.
-Normalement,
il faudrait rentrer...
Allez,
avec minimum,
le minimum, 40 kilos.
40, 50 kilos
ce serait bien.
Mais là...
Là, ça paye pas le gasoil.
-Avec son filet de 6 mètres,
Jonathan visait
des daurades royales,
l'un des poissons vendus
le plus cher à la criée,
entre 20 et 25 euros le kilo.
Il n'en a attrapé qu'une.
Donc, ça, c'est la daurade royale.
On la reconnaît
avec la tache jaune, là.
Après ça, c'est la daurade grise,
le griset.
Bon, elle n'est pas très grosse,
mais bon...
Ca, c'est le bar
qui fait partie aussi
des poissons de luxe,
on va dire.
Là, c'est archi nul.
Donc là, ouais, il y a...
6 poissons.
Aussi bien
avec le même nombre de filets,
j'aurais pu rentrer
avec 500 kilos
comme là, aujourd'hui,
avec 3 poissons.
-6 poissons pour 18 heures de pêche.
Pour Jonathan, le problème,
ce sont les chalutiers géants
qui ratissent les mers.
-Le poisson qu'ils pêchent, bon...
Ca fait partie de la nourriture
que nous, on recherche.
Et puis bon, bah eux,
c'est pour faire des...
Les trois quarts ou la moitié,
c'est pour nourrir
du poisson d'élevage.
Ils pensent que l'avenir
est dans l'élevage,
mais quand on compare le goût
d'un poisson d'élevage
avec un sauvage,
il n'y a pas photo, quoi.
Certes, le prix sera
plus intéressant, mais c'est tout.
-En France métropolitaine,
la pêche artisanale
représente 70 % des navires,
mais seulement 22 % des captures.
La pêche industrielle se taille
la part du lion.
Et aujourd'hui,
les mers se meurent.
Plus de 34 % des stocks marins
mondiaux sont surexploités.
C'est trois fois plus
que dans les années 70.
Les chalutiers géants
vident les océans
de leurs ressources
pour nourrir une population
qui consomme deux fois plus
de poissons qu'il y a 50 ans.
La pêche artisanale, elle,
déplore sa disparition programmée
et les fermes d'élevage de poissons
sont souvent vues
comme une solution à la surpêche.
Les scientifiques demandent
à ce que 30 % des océans
soient protégés
d'ici à 2030.
Nos modèles de pêche
et d'élevage de poissons
sont-ils soutenables ?
Deux visions s'opposent.
Olivier Le Nézet est président
du Comité national
des pêches maritimes
et des élevages marins,
et Didier Gascuel est professeur
en écologie marine
à l'Institut de Rennes.
-On est fiers de notre pêche.
La protection de la ressource
a été faite.
Il faut protéger le pêcheur.
-La ressource,
elle est en mauvais état.
L'abondance de la plupart
des espèces pêchées
est assez faible.
On a déjà vidé l'océan
d'une partie de ses poissons.
-L'ONG Sea Shepherd
documente
cette pêche industrielle en mer.
En décembre dernier, sa présidente,
Lamya Essemlali, et des militants
sont allés traquer
des chalutiers géants
au large de Boulogne-sur-Mer.
-Là, on est devant le Afrika,
je sais pas si vous arrivez
à voir un peu la démesure du bateau.
Donc, dans un filet comme celui-là,
ce bateau peut remonter
l'équivalent de la nourriture
de 30 000 phoques
en un coup de filet.
C'est énorme.
C'est une machine de guerre.
-Ce gigantesque navire est capable
de prélever
250 tonnes de poissons
en une journée.
Une pêche miraculeuse
qu'un pêcheur artisanal
atteindrait en cinq ans.
-On est arrivés sur le deuxième
en une demi-heure,
toujours un navire néerlandais
toujours dans les eaux
territoriales françaises.
-Sea Shepherd affirme
avoir comptabilisé en une semaine
9 chalutiers dans la Manche,
dont 6 dans les eaux territoriales
françaises,
soit à moins de 22 km des côtes.
Nous retrouvons sa présidente
en Bretagne
à son retour de mer,
avec le vidéaste de l'association,
Tanguy Le Duigou.
-La plupart des gens s'imaginent pas
la démesure de ces bateaux,
et puis surtout le fait
qui finalement,
ils pêchent
très, très près de la côte,
dans les eaux territoriales,
dans les aires marines protégées,
et ils pêchent des quantités
astronomiques de poissons.
-Une pêche qui n'est pas illégale,
même dans les aires protégées.
-Tous les oiseaux
nous tournaient autour.
-C'est impressionnant.
-C'est ainsi que 47 %
de ces navires industriels
pêchent dans ces aires marines
préservant l'écosystème marin.
Curieuse législation.
Alors que la France annonce
protéger plus de 30 % de ses eaux,
seules 0,005 % le sont réellement,
d'après l'association
de protection de la mer BLOOM.
-C'est beau, hein ?
Enfin, "c'est beau"...
C'est beau et c'est terrible
à la fois.
Les oiseaux marins,
ils sont clairement victimes
de la surpêche,
soit par des captures accidentelles,
soit parce qu'en fait,
on a des navires
qui pêchent beaucoup trop,
et donc, ça rend
leur capacité à s'alimenter
de plus en plus difficile.
L'océan, ce n'est pas
un hangar avec des stocks
qui sont cloisonnés et délimités.
Tout est interdépendant et connecté.
Les espèces interagissent.
-Et il y a encore pire,
figurez-vous.
Le chalut de fond
qui racle les fonds marins.
Rien ne lui échappe.
Et il est lesté par des poids
pesant parfois plusieurs tonnes.
-Les avancées sont fondamentales.
On a allégé le matériel.
Ils ne sont pas dans des zones
où il y a des coraux
ou des écosystèmes marins
vulnérables.
Donc les chalutiers de fond
ne travaillent pas
dans des zones sensibles.
-Il n'est pas sélectif.
Il ramasse tout sur son passage.
Or, une pêche durable,
c'est une pêche
où on ajuste le prélèvement.
"Tant de telle espèce",
et on fait une pêche chirurgicale
en ajustant exactement.
Le chalut ne le permet pas.
-Le secteur de la pêche
a bien compris
qu'il devait faire des efforts.
Des labels censés représenter
une pêche durable ont été créés.
Dans ce supermarché
de Fontenay-sous-Bois,
en Ile-de-France,
les poissons français
sont mis en avant
par le label Pavillon France.
Sur sa plancha,
l'animatrice Safia a choisi
des produits
qui ont mauvaise réputation.
-Messieurs, dames,
n'hésitez pas !
Aujourd'hui, dégustation
sur nos produits Pavillon France.
-Le but : attirer les clients
vers des poissons moins connus
pour diversifier leur consommation,
car, dans le monde,
près de 35 %
des ressources de la mer
sont surexploitées,
et en Méditerranée,
ce chiffre grimpe à 73 %.
-Ici, c'est de la vieille
en dégustation
et vous avez ici
du filet de harengs.
Alors j'ai mis que du sel,
du poivre,
sur un filet d'huile d'olive.
Allez-y, laissez-vous tenter.
Vous connaissez un petit peu
nos produits ?
-Non.
-C'est de la pêche responsable,
Pavillon France.
C'est une pêche responsable.
-Merci, c'est très bon.
-Je vous en prie.
-Problème :
toujours selon l'association BLOOM,
le fonctionnement des labels
et autres certifications
tend à privilégier
les flottes industrielles.
-Nous avons droit à 8 kilos
de poisson par an,
nous en mangeons 24,
donc 3 fois notre dose.
Quand les consommateurs
me demandent quoi faire,
mon premier conseil,
c'est de consommer moins de poisson.
-Il est important,
pour la diversité,
de manger aussi
des poissons de saison.
C'est ça qu'il faut aussi dire
aux Français et aux Françaises,
manger français.
-Peu importe son origine, le saumon
est le poisson favori des Français.
Le pays en est le deuxième
consommateur mondial,
avec presque 3 kilos
par personne et par an,
le plus souvent,
issu de fermes d'élevage.
Nous sommes à Isigny-sur-Mer,
en Normandie,
avec Pascal Goumain.
Voilà à quoi ressemble
une ferme aquacole.
Saumon de France produit 240 tonnes
de poisson chaque année.
Ici, quatre bassins
de 850 mètres cubes d'eau salée sont
en fonctionnement continu.
-En fin d'élevage,
on peut avoir,
dans chacun des bassins,
60 tonnes
de poissons au maximum.
Donc, ça dépend de la taille.
C'est pour ça que, comme nous,
on les pousse pas jusqu'au bout,
si vous considérez
des poissons d'un kilo,
ça vous fait au maximum
60 000 poissons.
-Ils ne sont destinés
qu'à une phase de pré-grossissement,
pour être ensuite introduits
en mer
dans la ferme marine
de l'entreprise.
Cette production sur terre
a beaucoup d'avantages.
-En ayant les systèmes au sol,
c'est pour ça que ça voit le jour
un petit peu partout,
c'est le seul endroit
où on peut monitorer
tous les paramètres pour assurer
les conditions optimales
d'élevage et de survie.
-Les saumons sauvages
se nourrissent de petits poissons,
de crustacés ou de crevettes.
Ici, ils n'ont droit
qu'à des croquettes.
-Nous, nos granulés,
ils sont constitués principalement
de farine de poisson.
Le poisson doit manger du poisson.
Genre des sardines,
des petits poissons minotiers,
en fait,
qui vont être capturés
principalement
dans les eaux du Chili.
-Et pour produire 1 kilo
de poissons d'élevage,
il faudrait compter
entre 2 et 5 kilos
de poissons sauvages.
Est-ce bien une solution
écologiquement compatible
à la surpêche ?
-C'est une idée, je pense,
absolument et totalement fausse.
Pour les élever, il faut leur donner
de la farine de poisson,
et cette farine de poisson,
il faut donc aller la pêcher en mer.
Donc chaque fois
qu'on mange un saumon,
on aggrave les problèmes
de surpêche.
Ces poissons sont pêchés
par des flottilles industrielles
dans les pays du Sud.
Donc, on pille les ressources du sud
pour nourrir les saumons des riches.
-Des élevages industriels
qui ne sont pas près de s'arrêter.
En Gironde,
l'entreprise Pure Salmon prévoit
de produire 10 000 tonnes
de saumon par an.
C'est 40 fois plus que la ferme
que nous venons de visiter.
Ce terrain deviendrait
le plus grand élevage intensif
aquacole terrestre du monde.
Bordeaux, en décembre dernier.
Esther Dufaure, représentante
de l'association
Eaux Secours Agissons...
-Salut, ça va ?
-...a donné rendez-vous
à ces militantes
pour une séance de tractage
contre une méga-usine de saumon.
-Si vous voulez donner
quelques mots sur le projet,
expliquez que c'est un projet
à l'échelle locale, en Gironde.
Rappelez que ce qui pose problème,
c'est la taille, les 10 000 tonnes.
La densité de poisson,
c'est 70 kilos de saumon
par mètre cube d'eau.
Et du coup, ils se touchent,
les saumons, ils se blessent,
ils se font mal,
il y a du cannibalisme...
C'est beaucoup de stress.
En termes de bien-être animal...
-Comme tous les animaux, entassés.
-C'est ça.
Musique intrigante
On se donne rendez-vous, dans
tous les cas, devant le tribunal.
-Devant le tribunal...
-Bonjour, monsieur !
-...parce que la militante écolo
y a un rendez-vous crucial.
-Gracias.
No hablo espanol.
Au revoir !
Bonjour, madame !
-Dans quelques minutes,
la justice rendra son verdict
après une plainte
en diffamation
de Pure Salmon.
L'entreprise,
portée par un fonds singapourien
basé à Abou Dabi,
dénonce une prise de parole
d'Esther Dufaure
devant la Commission européenne
et le lancement
d'une pétition en ligne
qui a rassemblé
plus de 55 000 signatures
contre l'usine.
-Contre l'élevage intensif
de saumons
qu'ils veulent implanter
en Gironde.
Il y a un QR code derrière
pour signer la pétition.
-C'est un peu
David contre Goliath.
C'est caricatural,
mais c'est ça.
-Une condamnation
ferait disparaître
l'association d'Esther Dufaure.
Quelques minutes plus tard...
-Ouiii !
Ca a marché !
-Eaux Secours Agissons
est relaxé.
-C'est un soulagement
et ça nous permet de continuer
en sachant que tout ce que l'on dit
est valable
et on a le droit de le dire.
Ca fait quand même
une grosse différence.
Du coup, merci beaucoup
pour le soutien.
C'est super.
-L'union fait la force.
-Oui.
-C'est ici,
au Verdon-sur-Mer,
à 100 km de Bordeaux,
que l'usine
devrait voir le jour.
Pour le maire,
Jacques Bidalun,
le projet est une aubaine.
A terme, il permettrait
de créer 250 emplois,
de quoi redynamiser
sa commune.
-Aujourd'hui,
on a là 64 enfants.
En 2008, il y en avait 100,
pratiquement.
Même si on n'a que 50,
100 emplois, je m'en fous,
il nous faut des emplois.
-Mais parmi
les 1300 habitants,
certains s'inquiètent.
-Vous êtes là,
l'usine sera là.
-Notamment,
des 3500 mètres cubes d'eau
qui seront rejetés chaque jour
dans l'estuaire de la Gironde.
-Ils auront
une station d'épuration.
Sa vocation, c'est de rendre
de l'eau propre.
L'eau qui sera rejetée
sera propre.
-Je dis que c'est
une vision productiviste,
qui consiste à penser
que ce qui est moderne,
c'est de produire
notre nourriture
dans des systèmes
de plus en plus artificialisés.
Aujourd'hui, on se dit
qu'il faut retisser
le lien avec la nature
et comment on fait,
compte tenu
de notre puissance destructrice,
pour continuer à vivre en harmonie ?
-Soutenez
la pêche française.
C'est aussi notre ADN
en tant que Français.
Notre littoral
est cher à tout le monde.
-La France
est le premier consommateur
de saumon en Europe,
250.000 tonnes
consommées en moyenne par an,
importées à 95 %.
Le reste est produit
sur place,
dans des élevages
qu'on a vus.
L'aquaculture vous semble
promise à un bel avenir ?
C'est une alternative
fiable ?
-Voilà une bonne question.
D'abord, il faut manger
du poisson français,
du poisson de pêche français,
si on veut être utile
et je crois
que votre reportage le montre.
L'aquaculture,
ça peut être une solution,
sur certaines espèces,
ça peut être utile
et c'est vrai qu'ils essayent
de faire des progrès
sur la composition de l'alimentation
des poissons d'élevage,
mais si vous voulez
protéger l'environnement,
ne mangez plus de saumon.
-Ce saumon d'élevage
présenté sous l'étiquette
saumon durable
et local vous fait bondir ?
-Oui.
Pourquoi on s'est mis
à produire
du saumon d'élevage
dans des enclos
gigantesques ?
La Norvège est le premier
pays producteur
et exportateur de saumon.
C'est calamiteux,
ce qu'il s'y passe,
parce qu'on a d'abord
surexploité
les saumons sauvages
et que la pêche commerciale
est allée quasiment
au bout de la logique
d'extinction de l'espèce
en milieu sauvage.
-Les stocks s'effondrent.
-Oui.
Aujourd'hui, le saumon,
c'est le "poulet de la mer".
En plus,
il n'est pas très bon
et on le retrouve
absolument partout.
-Toutes les boulangeries
proposent...
-Du thon ou du saumon.
-...en sandwich.
-C'est la peste
ou le choléra.
-Alors qu'avant,
c'était un plat de fête.
-Le saumon sauvage est excellent,
mais rare et très cher.
Vu l'état des stocks, il vaut mieux
s'en priver pendant un temps.
On vit très bien
sans saumon.
Et la consommation ?
A-t-on besoin de manger
deux fois plus de poisson,
comme dans le reportage,
d'avoir des protéines animales
à chaque repas, non.
-La France
est la deuxième
puissance maritime
au monde, pourtant,
les poissons qu'on consomme
sont majoritairement importés.
Où ça pêche ?
-C'est qu'à un moment donné,
notre mer,
qui a été surexploitée
depuis de nombreuses décennies,
voire plusieurs siècles,
a donné son maximum,
au niveau mondial,
autour des années 90.
Depuis 90, on sort...
-Le pic était en 1996.
-On sort plus,
on n'arrive pas à sortir
plus de protéines de la mer
depuis les années 90,
même en pêchant
toujours plus profond, plus loin
et de manière plus puissante.
C'est pour ça qu'on a fait appel
à l'aquaculture,
pour "venir au secours"
de la production de poisson.
C'est assez courant
dans l'histoire de l'humanité.
Dès qu'on n'arrive plus
à tirer de la nature
des choses
qu'elle nous donnait,
on installe
des systèmes de production.
-Avant de parler
des sujets qui fâchent,
un mot des abysses qui suscitent
beaucoup de convoitises.
La Norvège s'apprêtait à ouvrir
l'exploitation minière
de ses fonds marins en Arctique.
Grâce à la pression d'activistes
comme Camille Etienne,
la Norvège a reculé.
Elle explorera
d'abord ces fonds
avant de se décider ou non
à les exploiter.
Que cherchent-ils,
au juste ?
C'est l'heure du Climatoscope
sur la dernière lubie
de l'humanité.
-Qu'est-ce qu'on espère
trouver
au fond des mers ?
Des métaux,
pour les batteries
des voitures
ou l'électronique
des téléphones et ordinateurs,
car certaines zones,
certains fonds abyssaux
sont jonchés
de nodules métalliques
de la taille
d'une patate.
C'est comme un champ de patates
au fond de l'eau.
Ils contiennent du cobalt,
du nickel et du manganèse,
intéressants
pour la transition énergétique.
Alors, d'où viennent
ces patates métalliques ?
C'est bizarre de les voir
joncher le sol.
Ca provient
du métal qui s'accumule
dans les océans,
qui est en suspension
et qui finit
par descendre et s'accumuler,
puis se cristallise
sur un truc qui traîne.
Ca grossit
pendant des millions d'années
et puis ça forme
plein de patates métalliques
au fond des eaux.
C'est pas facile d'accès,
car ça va
jusqu'à 6000 mètres de profondeur
et ils ont déjà imaginé
des robots,
des espèces
de motoculteurs,
téléguidables
depuis la surface,
avec un aspirateur intégré.
Ca aspire
les patates métalliques,
ça les renvoie
vers le haut,
ça renvoie le sédiment
qui vient avec,
ça fait un énorme panache de fumée
et ça laisse derrière
une espèce de champ
complètement labouré.
Et le hic,
c'est que sur ces grands fonds,
il y a tout un écosystème,
c'est même le plus vaste
de la planète.
C'est pas un écosystème
luxuriant,
comme une forêt tropicale.
En bas, y a pas de lumière,
il fait 2 degrés,
il y a une pression de dingue,
pas grand-chose ne pousse,
c'est du sable, des cailloux,
mais de temps en temps,
il y a des créatures
improbables,
comme des poulpes à oreilles,
c'est assez saisissant,
ou encore
des éponges carnivores.
C'est un monde pauvre,
austère en apparence,
mais on estime qu'il y a
au moins un million d'espèces
qui y vivent
et dont on ne connaît rien.
C'est un écosystème
d'une fragilité extrême.
Tout tourne au ralenti,
on y a trouvé des coraux
âgés de 4000 ans,
des éponges vieilles
de 10 000 ans...
Tout était vraiment
extraordinairement stable,
immuable et donc,
très fragile.
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe
quand on envoie
une armada de motoculteurs
pour venir récupérer
des cailloux au fond ?
Tout ça balance un panache,
enfin, ça change tout
et ça crée un grand désordre.
On s'est demandé
ce que ça pouvait avoir,
comme impact.
On est en train d'essayer
de se rendre compte de ça.
Un étude a été faite
et montre
que 26 ans après le passage
d'un motoculteur, rien ne revient.
Les animaux
ne sont pas revenus depuis.
La conclusion
des scientifiques,
c'est que des animaux vont mourir,
des espèces vont disparaître
avant même qu'on les connaisse.
Des ONG et des scientifiques
réclament un moratoire
sur cette activité,
le temps
qu'on évalue les impacts,
mais les industriels
et les pays côtiers
sont un peu en embuscade,
comme la Norvège,
que vous mentionniez.
Il faudrait
peut-être réfléchir
avant de lancer les hostilités
dans cet endroit
qui est le seul à n'avoir pas été
affecté par l'activité humaine.
-Exploiter les abysses
serait une bombe
climatique en puissance.
Parlons du chalutage,
une méthode de pêche dévastatrice
pour les écosystèmes marins.
Les scientifiques
disent unanimement
qu'il faut en finir
avec le chalutage de fond
et créer
de toute urgence
des aires marines protégées
dignes de ce nom.
Vous leur donnez raison,
Pierre Karleskind ?
-Sur ce sujet du chalutage,
on est aujourd'hui
dans une situation
où les pêches européennes
dépendent beaucoup
de cet engin de pêche.
Si vous regardez les petits bateaux
qui sont derrière moi,
beaucoup pratiquent le chalut,
y compris pas très loin des côtes.
Sur ce sujet,
la question qui se pose,
c'est comment faire une transition
vers une pêche moins impactante
et regarder si on ne peut pas
changer le chalut ?
Je sais que certains
ne veulent pas entendre
qu'on puisse adapter le chalut,
mais des centres de recherches
proposent aujourd'hui des solutions
où le chalut se relève
et a nettement moins d'impact,
voire ne touche plus le fond.
Il est légèrement relevé,
ou bien, des situations
où le chalut
peut être sélectif.
Ca, aujourd'hui, on sait le faire.
L'intelligence artificielle
nous permet de le faire.
Donc si vous voulez,
nous avons devant nous
un objectif évident qui est
de réduire l'impact de la pêche
sur les écosystèmes.
Est-ce que ça passe
par une interdiction pure et simple
de cette technique sans regarder
ses capacités d'évoluer
ni regarder les conditions
socio-économiques
de son interdiction ?
La solution que je choisis,
elle est de dire : allons voir
territoire par territoire,
usage par usage,
écosystème par écosystème,
au cas par cas et sur le terrain.
-Je vous vois hausser
les sourcils
sur l'amélioration...
-L'intelligence
artificielle.
-...du chalutage.
-Ca fait des décennies
que les industriels de la pêche
et leurs alliés politiques
tiennent un discours du cas par cas
en disant : "Quand on s'est battus
contre la pêche en eau profonde,
"jusqu'à 2000 mètres de profondeur,
on a gagné l'interdiction en 2016
"de cette barbarie écologique."
Il y a
toutes les bonnes raisons
de ne pas croire ce discours
et de regarder scientifiquement
les impacts du chalutage.
Ils ne sont pas acceptables
du point de vue
de la biodiversité
et aussi d'un point de vue social
et économique.
La question, c'est de savoir
si on est d'accord sur le bilan,
et si on l'est,
on prend nos responsabilités
et on se met à piloter
l'action publique
de façon à ce qu'il n'y ait
aucune casse sociale
dans la transition des pêches.
-Le secrétaire d'Etat à la mer
disait que si
on interdisait le chalutage
dans les aires marines
protégées,
ça tuerait la filière.
Claire Nouvian,
vous avez initié
avec l'association BLOOM
un groupe de recherches
et vous avez présenté
vos conclusions
au Parlement européen.
Ce qui en ressort,
c'est que l'on peut
sauver l'océan et les emplois
si l'on s'en donne les moyens.
-Ce que l'on constate,
c'est qu'en résumé,
sans rentrer dans le détail,
on fait le constat qu'en termes
de création de richesses
par tonne débarquée,
- je rentre pas dans le détail
mais c'est la valeur ajoutée
des flottilles -
et qu'en termes d'emplois,
en fait, les meilleurs élèves,
ce sont
les bateaux équipés
en casiers, en filets
et en lignes,
et pas les chaluts.
C'est aussi
plutôt les petits navires,
même significativement,
qui ont un meilleur ratio
du point de vue de la richesse
et des emplois créés.
Sur la productivité écologique,
on constate aussi
qu'on a, sur les chaluts de fond,
les plus gros impacts.
Ils vont avoir les plus gros
problèmes en termes d'abrasion,
d'émissions de CO2
et de surexploitation,
selon la taille des flottes.
Et les plus vertueux,
ce sont ce qu'on appelle
les casiers, filets et lignes,
qui sont bons sur
tous les indicateurs sauf un,
les espèces sensibles, notamment
les cétacés et les oiseaux,
pour lesquels il y a
une grosse actualité.
-Pierre Karleskind,
vous avez forcément
lu un résumé de ce rapport.
Il en ressort effectivement
que le bilan est calamiteux
pour la pêche au chalut
et la pêche industrielle.
On fait un peu l'inverse
de ce qu'il faudrait faire ?
-"Calamiteux",
je pense qu'il faudrait apprendre
à être un peu dans la nuance
dans la façon de parler.
Le rapport ne dit pas "calamiteux".
Il établit clairement
qu'il est plus rentable
économiquement
comme environnementalement,
de faire de la ligne,
du filet, du casier.
La question, quand on est politique,
c'est : où on va ?
L'étude qui a été présentée
à l'instant par Harold Levrel
est extrêmement intéressante,
mais elle constitue en quelque sorte
une photo
de l'état instantané.
Or moi, si vous voulez,
si demain,
je dois prendre la décision
de faire passer
l'ensemble de la flotte de pêche,
qui aujourd'hui fait du chalut,
vers du filet, de la ligne
et du casier en côtier,
en fait, je ne sais pas faire.
Parce que vous aurez forcément
trop de bateaux qui vont faire
du filet en zone côtière,
trop qui vont faire du casier,
trop qui vont faire de la ligne,
et ça va pas rentrer.
Si je me permets cette analogie :
faire du boeuf de Kobe,
tout le monde sait
qu'environnementalement,
c'est moins impactant
que de faire du boeuf intensif,
et ça vous rapporte plus d'argent.
Simplement,
vous n'allez pas convertir
l'intégralité des éleveurs bovins.
C'est la même chose :
vous n'allez pas avoir le marché,
parce qu'il y a aussi
une question de marché.
La pêche au chalut est aussi
en quelque sorte une ossature
de l'alimentation,
du marché de poissons français.
Ca qui me manque profondément,
et là aussi,
je veux souligner le travail
de ma collègue Catherine Chabaud,
c'est une capacité
à développer des scénarios.
Catherine le propose
à travers la création
de l'équivalent du GIEC des océans,
c'est-à-dire des scientifiques
qui nous présentaient des scénarios,
et comment, nous, politiques,
nous pourrions aller
vers ces scénarios de transition.
Je ne suis pas du tout opposé
à cette idée de la transition.
Simplement, quelle est la bonne
solution pour ne pas se mettre
tout le monde en confrontation
sur une zone côtière
déjà bien exploitée ?
Si vous ajoutez
les énergies marines
renouvelables,
vous avez une petite impasse.
-Je vous laisse répondre.
-J'entends dans ce discours
un argument qui est de dire :
"Arrêtez tout."
Personne n'a dit ça.
On dit que ça fait depuis
au moins le début des années 2000
que les institutions publiques
françaises, y compris Matignon,
disent que le chalutage
de fond est une hérésie
environnementale et qu'il a
une faiblesse structurelle :
sa dépendance au gasoil
car il est très énergivore.
Les travaux de recherche
montrent
que la dépendance au gasoil fait
qu'il y a un énorme problème
de rentabilité
et que les flottes chalutières
sont moins rentables
que les engins dormants,
alors qu'elles sont beaucoup
plus subventionnées,
y compris les emplois.
Un emploi dans la pêche
industrielle,
y compris les chaluts de fond, etc.,
c'est un emploi subventionné
à hauteur de 60 000 euros par an
alors qu'un emploi
dans la pêche artisanale,
côtière,
dans des engins qui impactent moins
l'environnement,
est subventionné
à hauteur de 8
à 14 000 euros par an.
L'ensemble de la photo qu'on a
est un ensemble
qu'on connaît très bien
depuis fort longtemps.
On sait qu'on doit régler
ce problème d'impact écologique,
de non-productivité sociale,
pour en parler comme ça.
En gros, on est
sur des flottes chalutières
qui produisent deux à trois fois
moins d'emplois
que les flottes artisanales.
On sait qu'on vient
d'une calamité.
Maintenant, mettons un cap
pour commencer à construire
ensemble des scénarios.
C'est l'étape d'après.
Nous, on dit qu'on a un constat,
qu'on a le cap,
qu'on connaît
les impératifs écologiques :
l'océan est le poumon bleu
de la planète,
on a besoin qu'il soit fonctionnel
pour absorber du CO2,
l'état de dégradation des fonds
marins est extrême en Europe,
donc on a besoin
d'aller vers ce cap.
Comment on va y aller ?
C'est l'objet de la co-construction
qui s'ouvre à partir de maintenant.
-Pierre Karleskind,
comment on va y aller ?
-Alors moi, j'ai une question
dans tout ça.
Comment est-ce que je m'assure
que la somme de poissons
qui est pêchée
par cette filière chalutière,
nous pouvons la pêcher aussi avec
les autres techniques de pêche ?
Là est toute la question.
Si demain, vous vous retrouvez
dans une situation
où vous interdisez un type de pêche
dans les eaux européennes
et que vous n'êtes pas capables,
avec les autres techniques de pêche,
d'aller chercher ce poisson,
il va y avoir un vide sur le marché.
Or, le marché a horreur du vide,
le consommateur
va aller voir ailleurs,
et on va en fait acheter
plus de poissons importés.
On va importer du poisson
du reste du monde,
or, le reste du monde,
désolé de le dire,
il est pas plus vertueux que nous.
-Pour l'instant, on importe
95 % de notre consommation.
-On importe 70 %
de notre consommation,
c'est pas une raison
pour l'augmenter.
Donc vous allez vous retrouver
encore plus dépendant.
-Oui ?
-La réflexion des travaux,
c'est de réfléchir
à un volume constant et de savoir
ce qu'on peut améliorer
en faisant des transitions.
-Je suis vraiment très content
de ces travaux,
je veux le dire.
On a suffisamment l'occasion
de se disputer avec Claire Nouvian
et d'autres.
Ces travaux sont utiles
et permettent de mettre
des données objectives.
Mais il faut bien mettre en avant
l'ensemble des données du problème,
et je serai heureux
de pouvoir continuer à réfléchir
sur ces scénarios à établir.
Je ne peux que vous encourager
à nous les proposer.
-D'autant que les études montrent
que plus on protège
les aires marines,
plus les stocks sont importants.
Les tonnages de poissons
doublent.
Tout le monde est gagnant.
Harold Levrel ?
-Vous avez raison
de rappeler ça.
C'est un élément qui est aujourd'hui
bien connu des scientifiques :
quand on laisse
se reposer la nature,
elle devient plus productive.
Revenons sur la transition.
C'est toujours
un sujet hyper complexe.
On parle d'un quotidien
de milliers
de personnes
qui vont devoir
s'inventer une nouvelle vie
professionnelle,
et c'est pas trivial,
quand on a 20 ans d'activité.
Pour autant, il y a des choses
qu'on sait faire
qui poseraient pas
des défis énormes.
Par exemple, la langoustine,
on sait la pêcher au chalut
ou au casier.
C'est très facile,
entre guillemets.
Je simplifie, mais c'est facile
de pouvoir
imaginer avoir une pêche
à la langoustine
uniquement au casier.
On a un autre exemple :
le bar, on peut le pêcher au chalut
ou à la ligne.
Au chalut,
c'est un poisson qui arrive
tout tassé, qui n'a pas du tout
la même saveur
que le bar de ligne.
On va le vendre
moins cher, parce qu'on a
un meilleur rendement,
mais à un moment donné,
qu'est-ce qu'on veut
comme produits de la mer
dans nos assiettes ?
Quelle est la fréquence
de notre consommation ?
Ces deux exemples sont concrets
et faciles à imaginer,
sans fausse démagogie.
J'ajouterai un dernier élément
par rapport à ça :
les subventions bénéficient
principalement,
que ce soit en tonnage débarqué,
en termes de rentabilité,
quels que soient
les indicateurs qu'on utilise,
aux grands chaluts de fond,
aussi pélagiques,
mais principalement de fond,
et ça, ça pose question.
-Je vais la poser
à Pierre Karleskind :
il ne faudrait pas
mieux flécher
ces subventions,
les redistribuer plutôt selon
l'utilité sociale des navires,
voire sous condition
de durabilité ?
*-Oui. Aujourd'hui,
on a adopté un fonds européen
pour les affaires maritimes,
la pêche et l'aquaculture,
qui n'est pas un instrument
qu'on distribue
de façon proportionnelle
à la quantité de poissons pêchés
par les différents bateaux.
-Non, mais moins de 20 %
des subventions à la pêche
versées en France
au cours des dernières années
ont financé des activités
à caractère durable,
selon les chiffres officiels.
*-Je me sens plutôt à l'aise
sur le sujet.
Dans la négociation
avec les Etats membres
que nous avons eue sur ce FEAMPA
dont je viens de parler,
ce fonds européen,
nous avions voulu consacrer,
ça, c'était la position
du Parlement européen,
25 % de ce fonds
sur les opérations relatives
à la protection de la biodiversité.
Dans la négociation,
les Etats membres
ont été inflexibles
et ont demandé
à ce que ce soit réduit à 10 %.
Donc, si vous voulez,
à un moment,
je porte un certain nombre
de positions.
Je ne suis pas responsable du fait
que ce n'est pas celles
qui finalement sont adoptées
par la majorité,
en tout cas,
dans la négociation européenne.
-Très vite,
parce qu'on est en retard,
des subventions vont
vers des monstres marins.
BLOOM, Claire Nouvian, a montré
qu'il y avait des chalutiers géants
dans les eaux françaises
et les aires marines protégées.
Le plus grand chalutier pélagique
du monde, 145 m de long,
un monstre,
je ne sais pas si on peut le voir,
arrive en France.
Vous confirmez ?
*-Tout à fait. J'ai lu la presse,
j'ai vu qu'il allait arriver.
Je vous avoue
que ça me laisse
plus que perplexe,
parce qu'en plus,
ayant eu en charge la gestion
des ports bretons quelques années,
je sais que ce bateau ne rentre pas
dans le port de Saint-Malo.
Donc, il ne va pêcher...
Il va avoir une activité en mer.
-Pierre Karleskind,
il va être racheté
par la compagnie des pêches
de Saint-Malo.
Il ne rentre...
*-C'est bien ça,
mon problème.
Il ne rentre pas dans le port.
Il va aller pêcher potentiellement
dans les eaux françaises,
avoir son activité à bord
et il va débarquer probablement
à IJmuiden,
qui est déjà son port d'attache
aux Pays-Bas.
Moi, je vois franchement pas
l'intérêt de voir arriver
ce genre de navire de pêche
dans la flotte française.
-Beaucoup à dire.
Le gouvernement autorise
ce genre de transaction.
Comme M. Karleskind est un député
de la majorité présidentielle,
c'est une bonne idée
de s'opposer à cette transaction,
autorisée. C'est en remplacement
d'un autre navire de 90 mètres
pour faire
du surimi industriel.
Peut-on vivre sans surimi ?
La réponse est oui.
Monsieur Karleskind,
comme il le précise,
on est souvent...
en chamailleries,
tous les deux,
parce qu'il a voté,
pas plus tard que le 18 janvier,
pour continuer à permettre
d'autoriser ces immenses navires,
chalutiers, pélagiques
ou pélagiques de fond,
ça peut être du pélagique
ou ceux qui raclent les fonds,
alors qu'on avait
une proposition
d'un rapport d'initiative
au Parlement votée le 18 janvier
et qui permettait de se positionner
contre ces navires
industriels et la question
des navires de plus de 25 m,
qui rentrent
dans les eaux françaises
et en concurrence
avec les pêcheurs français,
c'est le coeur du débat
de l'histoire de la transition.
On peut dire qu'on va la faire.
Ce serait bien de commencer
par interdire ces bateaux
qui prennent, en volume,
ce que des milliers de pêcheurs
peuvent prendre au quotidien.
Si on veut redynamiser
notre littoral,
notre économie... Vous savez
ce que c'est, le problème
de la pêche artisanale :
c'est de l'accès à du quota
et à des zones de pêche.
Or, ces monstres marins,
qui viennent
à 3 milles des côtes pêcher,
au nez et à la barbe
des pêcheurs côtiers,
c'est une grande provocation.
Donc, M. Karleskind,
on va continuer à se voir
au Parlement européen,
à avoir des échanges verts,
parce que les éléments de langage
dans les médias, tout va bien,
on est dans des généralités.
Quand on rentre
dans le concret de vos votes,
vous n'êtes pas du tout
au rendez-vous.
J'aimerais comprendre pourquoi
vous ne vous opposez pas
à la présence de navires industriels
dans les eaux françaises
si vous vous dites en faveur
de la pêche côtière française.
*-Il y a une différence
entre 25 m et 145 m.
En fait, quand vous dites 25 m,
vous vous attaquez à une partie
de la flotte de pêche européenne,
qui n'est pas forcément faite
que de bateaux industriels.
Moi, je trouve regrettable
que vous essayiez
de balayer d'un revers de main
l'ensemble de la pêcherie européenne
en essayant de mettre
dans le même panier
les bateaux de 25 m et 150 m.
-Vous ne pouvez pas dire ça.
Vous avez abattu vos cartes.
Les statistiques sont formelles.
97 % de la flotte française
est composée de bateaux
qui font moins de 25 m.
Quand vous dites : "Vous voulez
"balayer la flotte
industrielle européenne",
c'est pas vrai.
On veut s'attaquer au 1 à 3 %.
En Allemagne, c'est 1 % des navires.
En France, 3 %.
Ces bateaux vont capturer
jusqu'à la moitié des débarquements.
On est sur un pur problème
d'injustice sociale.
Vous êtes dans le déni scientifique.
Vous êtes en train de dire que
quand il vous faire transitionner
3 % de la flotte française
des plus destructeurs
socialement et écologiquement,
vous n'est pas au rendez-vous.
C'est clair.
Dans le prochain Parlement,
si vous êtes réélu,
on aura beaucoup de travail.
Il faudra commencer par le constat.
*-Je regrette que vous n'ayez pas
beaucoup de nuance
et ne soyez pas capable
de comprendre qu'entre 25 et 145,
il y a énormément
de différence.
-Les pêcheurs et le comité régional
des pêches de Normandie demandent
l'interdiction des bateaux
de plus de 25 m.
-On n'arrivera pas
à vous réconcilier aujourd'hui.
Sans transition, cette question :
peut-on réparer
ce que l'homme a détruit ?
C'est ce que s'efforce de faire
une entreprise montpelliéraine,
qui repeuple les océans
et restaure la biodiversité
dans les ports français.
Depuis 2015,
elle a relâché plus
de 17 000 poissons en Méditerranée.
Le monde de demain
commence aujourd'hui.
Emma Guizot et Ibar Aibar.
-Sur le grand port
maritime de Marseille
se trouve une entreprise
qui repeuple la mer.
Ces drôles de cages
sont ce qu'ils appellent
des biohuts,
des refuges
pour les jeunes poissons.
Anthony,
technicien aquacole d'Ecocean,
s'occupe de les installer en mer
dans les zones côtières
dégradées par l'homme.
-Je vais les mettre comme ça.
On a beaucoup bétonné
dans des zones portuaires.
On va avoir des digues
avec des gros blocs,
des quais lisses en béton.
Les espèces ne vont pas pouvoir
trouver d'habitat et se cacher.
On y voit plein
de gros poissons,
mais au final, ils vont manger
les petits et sans les petits,
il n'y aura pas de gros.
Ce que j'ai ici à côté,
ce sont des biohuts,
l'équivalent des maisons
à insectes en milieux aquatiques.
C'est là qu'on va avoir
les poissons, les jeunes,
qui vont graviter et se nourrir
de ce qui va se développer
dans les coquilles d'huîtres
et se protéger des prédateurs
dans cet espace
de grille,
qui est donc en façade.
-Pondues par leurs géniteurs
en mer, ces larves de poissons
sont à la merci
des prédateurs.
1 % d'entre elles trouvent
leur chemin jusqu'aux côtes
pour s'y abriter
pendant leur croissance.
Sans ces habitats marins
artificiels,
aucune ne survivrait.
Il y aurait 100 % de perte.
Suspendus par des chaînes
ou sanglés autour de poteaux,
ces biohuts sont installés dans
une trentaine de ports en France.
Anthony s'assure que les larves
aient le gîte et le couvert.
-C'est un biohut
qui est à l'eau
depuis deux ans, environ.
On a une petite algue.
On a ici un petit nudibranche
qui se balade, ici.
La faune et la flore
se sont développées sur ces grilles
et apportent la fonction nourricière
aux jeunes poissons.
-La société a développé
un autre système, plus efficace,
pour cette fois-ci essayer
de sauver plus de 90 %
de larves de poissons,
dévorées par les prédateurs.
Ecocean fait
capturer ces juvéniles
de quelques millimètres de long
par des pêcheurs du coin
pour les élever à l'abri
dans de petits bassins
pendant plusieurs mois.
C'est Damien Einsargueix,
le chef biologiste,
qui s'assure de la bonne santé
de ces nouveaux arrivants.
-La première phase qu'on a,
c'est les acclimater,
les identifier
et aussi savoir si...
les post-larves ou larves
sont capables de bien se nourrir.
On les place, justement,
dans ces aquariums-là.
C'est une phase critique pour nous,
l'acclimatation.
C'est des animaux qui sont fragiles,
qui sont stressés.
-Le taux de survie des bébés
accueillis dans le labo
est de 80 %.
Une fois les 3 cm atteints,
ils vont dans des bassins occultants
pour éviter le contact humain.
-C'est très simple
de domestiquer un poisson.
On a des espèces qui sont curieuses,
qui vont venir voir.
Nous, on ne veut pas ça.
On veut, quand on les repeuple,
quand ils regagnent la grande bleue,
qu'ils fusionnent avec des espèces
restées dans le milieu
et qu'on arrive pas à dissocier
qui est issu de la ferme
et qui est resté dans le milieu.
Et surtout, qu'il y ait
un comportement préservé, inné,
de chasse et de comportement social
avec d'autres espèces.
Ca permet, dès qu'il y a
un prédateur, de se dire :
"Je m'en vais."
Alors que s'il y a déjà
un lien avec l'homme,
on peut avoir une modification
du comportement.
Et ça,
on ne veut pas du tout.
Musique douce
-Au bout de six mois,
ces poissons mesurent 7 cm
et sont suffisamment développés
pour survivre en milieu naturel.
Ils sont alors relâchés en mer,
exactement là
où ils avaient été capturés.
...
Il s'agit de restaurer
l'écosystème marin,
et les stocks de poissons
pour la pêche.
...
Depuis sa création en 2015,
Ecocean a réintroduit
environ 20 000 poissons.
Une façon de rendre
à la Méditerranée
une infime partie
de ce qu'elle nous donne
depuis des millénaires.
...
-Ce reportage montre
qu'on a des solutions
à portée de main.
Que pourrait-on faire autrement ?
Augmenter la taille
des filets ?
-Il y a un peu de perplexité
autour de cette idée de...
d'accélérer
la restauration de la nature,
mais c'est bizarre de se dire
qu'on va mettre en place
des solutions financiarisées
de repeuplement,
alors que simultanément,
on ne protège pas.
Vous l'avez mentionné.
Les aires marines
ne sont pas du tout protégées
et le chalutage de fond
est encore autorisé,
avec des votes
dont on a parlé,
et qui ont généré un peu
les altercations qu'on peut avoir
avec Pierre Karleskind,
parce qu'on est en désaccord
très profond là-dessus.
Le gouvernement français se refuse
à faire l'évidence
au niveau international,
suivre la commission européenne
d'interdire le chalutage
de fond et à côté de ça,
on repeuple ?
C'est un peu bizarre.
-Pierre Karleskind,
qu'attend-on pour protéger
les aires marines ?
Aujourd'hui,
la protection stricte
ne concerne que, je crois,
0,5 % de notre territoire maritime,
à peine.
*-Claire Nouvian dit
qu'on a un désaccord profond,
je ne suis pas d'accord.
Je suis d'accord pour interdire
le chalut de fond
sur les espèces de fond sensibles,
pardon, pas les espèces,
les habitats qui sont sensibles.
-Dans les aires marines protégées ?
*-Oui.
-Mais vous avez voté contre,
le 18 janvier.
*-J'ai voté contre,
comme vos collègues
du groupe
des sociaux-démocrates qui,
globalement, ont refusé...
-Non, pas les Français.
*-Les sociaux-démocrates,
globalement, ont voté
contre la proposition,
qui était
d'interdire globalement,
dans toutes les aires marines
protégées, le chalutage de fond,
pour dire ce que j'ai dit au début :
"Allons-y au cas par cas."
-Les scientifiques ne parlent pas
du cas par cas,
mais de la nécessité
de protéger 30 % des aires marines.
30 %, pas du cas par cas.
Qu'est-ce que vous leur répondez ?
*-Alors là,
je ne vous rejoins pas.
Je ne vous rejoins pas,
parce que
les scientifiques disent
qu'il faut protéger 30 %.
Après, au sein de ces 30 %,
les mesures précises de conservation
doivent correspondre
à ce que vous cherchez à protéger.
C'est pour ça
qu'il y a ce cas par cas.
-C'est arbitré
par l'union internationale...
*-Vous devez avoir des objectifs
concrets de protection,
mais quand il s'agit
de mettre en oeuvre,
vous devez vous mettre
dans chaque aire marine protégée.
-Vous allez contre
les avis scientifiques,
contre la diplomatie internationale.
C'est très difficile.
C'est indéfendable, votre position.
-Vous avez derrière moi
des bateaux de pêche,
que vous proposez
de mettre à l'arrêt,
parce qu'ils vont pêcher
dans le parc marin d'Iroise.
-Non protégé.
-Ils pratiquent des engins de fond
dans le parc marin d'Iroise,
parce qu'il y a des endroits
dans le parc marin...
-Vous êtes d'accord
sur un point,
c'est que...
*-A Iroise,
il est possible de pêcher,
parce que le fond ne présente pas
un enjeu de sensibilité
particulièrement important.
-C'est faux !
Encore une énormité !
Dans vos retranchements,
vous dites n'importe quoi.
Non, c'est faux.
*-Je dis n'importe quoi ?
Dans le parc marin d'Iroise,
des endroits ne sont pas
ultrasensibles.
-Vous vous rendez compte
de ce que vous dites ?
*-J'ai fait 20 ans d'études
sur ce parc d'Iroise !
-Ce parc n'a pas d'enjeu
de protection ?
*-Bien sûr que si, mais pas
dans l'intégralité du parc.
-Poursuivons
cette conversation
au Parlement. Avec plaisir.
*-Je préfère sur le terrain.
Les discussions dans les salons
parisiens ne m'intéressent pas.
-Demandons une émission
de plusieurs heures.
-Avec joie. Impossible
de se quitter sans donner
la parole à celle
qui se démène
pour que notre avenir soit vivable.
Camille Etienne a réussi à infléchir
la position de la Norvège
sur l'exploitation
de ses abysses.
Elle a tenu à nous dire ça.
C'est l'heure de sa carte verte.
Camille,
nous sommes tout ouïe.
-La technologie
ne nous sauvera pas.
Pour une fois, je ne céderai pas
aux formules littéraires,
comme j'aime le faire. Plutôt,
laissez-moi vous le démontrer
de manière mathématique
pour tenter de convaincre
les plus rationnels
d'entre vous.
Accordez-moi une formule,
celle du navigateur Eric Tabarly.
"L'océan, c'est ce qu'on a
dans le dos quand on va à la plage."
Pendant très longtemps,
je n'ai pas pensé à l'océan.
Ou du moins,
j'y pensais peu.
Il avait le goût de vacances,
la couleur des cartes postales.
Un léger embrun qui accompagnait
nos enfances. De loin,
un tendre décor
qui apaise les chagrins
et rend cinématographique
la solitude.
Je me sentais mal à l'aise
dans ses bras.
Comme un vertige à l'envers.
Ses abysses mystérieux,
dont j'avais peur qu'ils m'avalent,
comme on a peur du monstre
sous son lit.
Cet horizon brouillé
qui rend vulnérable, parce qu'alors,
rien ne peut s'y prévoir.
Tout peut y surgir.
Ce silence sourd, qui ne nous laisse
d'autre choix que d'écouter,
ce qui nous arrange
de ne pas entendre.
Nous entretenons avec l'océan
un rapport principalement poétique,
peu politique.
L'océan, notre part d'ombre,
l'angle mort de nos marches,
de nos soulèvements,
de nos colères.
On lui tourne le dos pour aller
dorer sur nos serviettes.
Et cette distance rend la guerre
qui s'y déroule invisible.
Vous me direz,
ce ne sera pas la première.
Je parle de guerre à dessein,
parce qu'on a déclaré la guerre
aux poissons.
Ce n'est pas moi qui ai été séduite
par la rhétorique de la phrase
pour faire dans l'air du temps.
C'est Daniel Pauly,
spécialiste mondial
des ressources marines.
On a déclaré la guerre
aux poissons.
La pêche industrielle vient de là.
GPS, sonar acoustique :
on utilise
des technologies inventées
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
qu'on applique contre les poissons.
C'est comme pour les arbres.
Si on en coupe plus vite
qu'il n'en repousse,
on se retrouve
sur un sol désert.
Alors, les scientifiques ont établi
un seuil maximal.
Au-delà de celui-ci,
il y a plus de poissons pêchés
que de poissons
qui naissent.
Mathématiquement,
on court à leur disparition.
Plus d'un tiers des espèces
de poissons sont pêchées
au-delà de ce seuil et 100 % frôlent
la limite de ce seuil.
Il n'y en aura plus.
C'est mathématique.
On vide littéralement
l'océan de sa vie.
C'est mathématique.
Voyez vous-mêmes :
dans les années 90,
on atteint un pic.
A l'époque, 130 millions de tonnes
de poissons étaient pêchées par an.
Depuis, nous ne vivons
qu'un inéluctable déclin.
La surenchère
technologique a beau s'affairer,
les immenses filets des chaluts
ont beau racler les fonds
sur des kilomètres,
on a beau inventer des machines
pour pêcher plus profond,
plus loin des côtes,
attraper à l'aide de bateaux-usines
bientôt trop grands
pour entrer dans les ports
de nouvelles espèces,
qui avaient été épargnées
de notre envie de les avaler,
nous devons nous y résoudre :
nous avons atteint les limites
de ce que la nature peut
nous donner,
de ce qu'on peut lui prendre.
La pêche est la première activité
humaine à atteindre un plafond.
La surenchère technologique
ne permet pas de compenser
l'effondrement des ressources.
Une sacrée leçon
qui nous tape dans l'épaule,
puisqu'on a gardé l'océan
dans le dos.
On pourrait s'arrêter,
être raisonnables.
Plutôt, quand nos eaux occidentales
sont quasiment vides, on y est,
nous allons piller
dans les eaux du sud.
Le port de Lorient se met
à importer du poisson d'Oman.
On pille à tel point
que certains pays, tel le Sénégal,
n'ont plus de poissons
pour leurs habitants.
On a tout pris
pour du surimi,
de la farine de poisson,
des élevages de saumons.
Cette course à la technologie
a un coût, de plus en plus élevé.
Alors,
on coupe les coûts où on peut.
Les cas d'esclavage sont
de plus en plus fréquents
comme dans la pêche au thon,
comme le dévoile BLOOM.
C'est un choix politique.
La pêche artisanale,
qui nourrit beaucoup mieux le monde
en ne surexploitant pas
les ressources,
est la première à en pâtir.
Un pêcheur industriel
reçoit en moyenne
187 fois plus
de subventions au gasoil par an
qu'un pêcheur artisanal.
Pourtant,
il y a une solution.
Pour une fois,
efficace et flemmarde.
La meilleure chose à faire,
ce serait de faire moins,
de se retourner
et de voir qu'il suffit
de ne pas alimenter cette guerre
pour qu'elle cesse.
La paix dans l'océan
est à une portée de courage :
celui de déposer les armes
et en l'occurrence,
la plus dangereuse d'entre elles :
la pêche industrielle.
-Pierre Karleskind,
le monde a déclaré
la guerre aux poissons,
comme le dit Camille Etienne.
*-Il y a une chose
qui est sûre,
c'est que s'il y a
une partie du poisson
qu'il faut renoncer à manger,
c'est le poisson d'importation.
Comme vous l'avez fort bien dit,
on va piller chez les autres.
Or, si vous enlevez
le poisson d'importation,
vous divisez par 3
votre consommation de poisson.
C'est ce que Didier Gascuel
suggérait,
en termes de réduction
de la consommation.
Mangez du poisson français,
pas du poisson d'importation.
-Dernier mot : dire aux armateurs,
aux chalutiers, aux pêcheurs :
"Vous n'êtes pas les rois
de la mer, des acteurs du milieu,
"mais pas les propriétaires
d'un bien commun.
"Essayons de construire
une filière durable",
est-ce que
c'est si difficile ?
*-C'est compliqué,
quand vous êtes face à des gens
qui ont investi beaucoup d'argent,
d'eux-mêmes, de leur vie.
Vous avez des pêcheurs artisans
qui se sont endettés
à hauteur de 3 millions d'euros
pour acheter un navire de 18 m,
par exemple.
Ce sont ces personnes à qui
vous êtes obligé de dire...
Vous ne pouvez pas leur dire :
"Vous allez arrêter et changer."
Effectivement,
on a un énorme travail
sur comment est-ce qu'on fait
la transition.
La suite de l'étude
proposée par BLOOM
sera extrêmement utile
et nécessaire, surtout.
-Merci à tous les trois.
Avant de se quitter,
des recommandations de lecture :
"La pêchécologie" de Didier Gascuel,
aux éditions Quae.
Du même auteur,
aux éditions Actes Sud,
"Pour une révolution
dans la mer".
Ce livre, "Océans",
chez La Relève et La Peste.
Une infographie de la mer
extrêmement bien faite,
aux éditions du CNRS,
et ce livre
de Jean-Baptiste Fressoz,
"Sans transition",
dont vous vouliez parler,
Claire Nouvian.
-Oui, c'est mon coup de coeur
en ce moment.
Ce chercheur du CNRS a reconstruit,
en fait, l'histoire
des énergies
et il montre qu'il n'y a jamais eu
de transition énergétique.
On a cumulé
toutes les énergies,
au lieu de les remplacer.
Le bois n'a pas remplacé le charbon.
Le charbon n'a pas remplacé
le pétrole.
Ils se sont cumulés
pour nous donner plus de confort,
une matérialité
incroyablement infinie,
dans des limites planétaires
qui elles sont bien finies.
Et donc,
l'enjeu de la transition,
il est très complexe.
Il passe nécessairement
par une refonte
de notre pensée économique,
pour se dire :
est-ce qu'on peut passer
d'une économie basée sur des désirs
à une économie qui est basée
sur des besoins ?
-C'est à lire, donc.
On se quitte sur ces mots.
Je vous retrouve le mois prochain
pour une émission consacrée
aux déchets,
qui ne sera pas à jeter.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...